welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Boss and Guardians of the Galaxy vol 3
is released to new trailer footage from
an international promo and some other
interesting 40x shots we haven't
properly discussed and since we now know
the film will be 2 hours and 29 minutes
long with James Gunn promising quote not
a second it's wasted there's no fat I
assume every single one of these frames
is doing some burpees I liked that Pratt
a bit better personally but let's break
down these new shots for all the protein
that we missed and by the way over on
our new channel the Deep dive and the
weeks leading up to Guardians volume 3 I
will be doing a re-watch of Guardians
volume 1 and volume 2. you're definitely
going to want to subscribe for those
videos and for all of our great content
over there okay let's take a look at
this promo released on the Marvel Korea
YouTube account hi Guardians
are you ready for One Last Ride let's
give the Galaxy something to remember us
bye
sit up what is here for tracks it's
called a sofa it's not a bed what we
find it hard to believe it doesn't have
a multiple purposes doesn't really
matter does it I'm sorry my friend is
stupid I'm hungry all right
quite a few new shots here there's a new
angle of swole group extended as
branches to carry multiple guns in a
shootout with a high evolutionary
scientists in addition to his two main
arms I count six additional branches
making him a step up from Doc Ock with
his four additional arms I love this
because it shows the real purpose of
swole groot's nature and his form
basically that bulk is just to hide a
bunch of snaking branches that could be
used for all these different functions
okay so not an ounce of fat in that shot
all muscle check okay then Gamora tosses
a lid as she drinks something on the
Bowie ship this is actually the first
time we can look at the inner structure
of the Bowie behind her the Bowie is
much larger than the guardian's past two
ships the Milano and the Benetar the
Bowe can house larger cargo and smaller
crafts if need be then rocket sips what
looks like some boba tea but the case
behind him is a label with some orange
writing in the cree language the top
word translates to milky and I'm just
wondering what mammal they milked to get
this stuff was it Bova one of Herbert
windham's other creations the nurse made
dewanimax
on Mount wundergore in the comics now
during this we hear Rockets say let's
give the Galaxy something to remember us
by with this new shot of him behind the
wheel in an image that Empire just
released a clear shot of I'm wondering
if this could be when rocket goes alone
to counter Earth to explore his past
requiring the rest of the Guardians to
go looking for him because in all the
other shots we see the Guardians walking
off the Bowie into that suburb rocket is
not with them we got a pretty great axle
shot of Rocket suspended in the air
cameras zipping around him and then he
fires downward as he drops I feel like
this is part of the same sequence as
Peter Quill and Groot fighting the
soldiers in a similar looking hallway
quill rolling up on a knee to shoot up
or toward the right but here you cannot
help but love the look of Glee on
Rocket's face as he flies through the
air the camera is zipping around in
midair feels like the kind of thing the
wachowskis would do on Trinity when she
jumped in the Matrix something that if
he saw movies in the early odds every
freaking movie had one of these shots
thank you
once again we see quill and more looking
into each other's eyes as gamar holds
blurp this is a furry little monster we
still don't know very much about oven
you'll probably be able to buy him in
the mission breakout gift shop at
California Adventure now we work crazy
hours to get these videos out to you as
soon as we can our lunch hours can be
more like our lunch 15 minutes luckily
we have some hopsco e-bikes in the
office to ZIP down the street to grab
some food from a nearby restaurant
ahavsko e-bike can go up to 28 miles per
hour with pedal assist the bike has a
range of up to 60 miles throttle only
and up to 80 if you don't mind pumping
your legs a bit even if you live in
hilly hilly San Francisco like I do
uphill riding is still smooth and easy
the hills of San Francisco have met
their match with the torque sensor pedal
assist great for starting from stop on a
hill also very very fun the high quality
88 volt Samsung LG lithium battery will
keep your bike and your flashlight going
and they're a blast to ride folks in the
office are always fighting for who gets
to ride to pick up lunch all hopsco
e-bikes come with a two-year warranty in
free shipping and right now they're
having a sale on some of their most
popular models if you enter promo code
Rockstar 100 at checkout you'll get an
additional 100 off your purchase there's
never been a better time to get an
e-bike and hopsco is hooking us up head
to hopsco.com to find the bike that's
right for you and don't forget to use
promo code Rockstar 100 for an
additional 100 off your purchase then
our villain
Ouija as a high evolutionary Herbert
Wyndham sits cross-legged floating as
his armor glows and it moves down this
Burning Corridor the light up suit does
remind me a lot of Kang's neurokinetic
suit in Quantum media I believe there
may be a connection between the tech
worn by both villains then there's this
interesting shot I haven't been really
able to make out what it is but
something is scaling up a ladder in a
mechanical exoskeleton we get an
extended version of all these windows
opening up looks like within each
glowing container something is inside of
each of them might be a bunch of
captives that are now being freed we'll
see then rocket after his cruel surgery
by the high evolutionary you can see his
arms now Stumpy and he's standing on his
hind legs pointing and laughing in his
cage just a nice moment he's likely
sharing with the love of his life Lila
then the Guardians pilot the Bowie added
his pink fleshy structure as some of
those floating soldiers fire on them I
really think we might be looking at the
tissue or the optical nerve of a
Celestial maybe even tissue that used to
reside inside of nowhere something that
I've theorized Taylor Tavon and the
Devon Corporation might be my need for
more Celestial nerd matter just fine why
Tavon was willing to part ways with
nowhere then quill nebula Gamora drags
the Mantis slowly make their way out of
this bizarre facility as yellow liquid
is exploding behind them and all these
figures in these flesh-colored bulky
suits are floating around on the screens
in the background to the right that is
definitely Herbert Windham in his purple
suit then shot of Adam Warlock beating
the hell out of someone in the nowhere
setting find them in a yellow glowing
sign also in Cree translating to oddly
the name Thomas
t-h-o-n-a-s now I looked it up there are
a few crew people this could be named
after like a Haley Thomas was a
compositor for the Guardians holiday
special and Thomas revolve did
uncredited digital composition work for
the Guardians holiday special it seems
like the crew who worked on that special
might have also worked on this upcoming
film otherwise we're looking for
Thomas's and Marvel there's of course
Thomas Holland there's Tommy wanna
maximoff's son and there's the Tank
Engine that Cassie Lang loves now this
promo ends with the Guardians visiting a
family in that 1980s decorated counter
Earth with its suburbs populated by
these animalistic hybrids and their
growing pain sweaters Drax crashes on
the sofa like it's a bed sidetracking
them from talking to these parents like
you can see in their 80s growing pain
style family portraits on the rolls they
do have kids in this family the yellow
wallpaper behind Drax shows a pattern of
figures swinging on swings walking past
fences they look like animalistic zebra
heads there's also an ashtray on the
side table beside Drax telling us that
these families still smoke indoors I
don't know why Drax is being so fussy
and annoying in the scene to be honest
for a two and a half hour movie that
supposedly doesn't have any fat on it I
think some people might pinch these love
handles but let's be fair this is a
trailer clip shown out of context for an
international market you're not exactly
the target demo of boo they're trying to
Market it's movie too with this cut but
earlier this month there was all also a
supposed 40x trailer regarding volume 3
released on a YouTube channel called
film extra which isn't really a
legitimate Source from what we can tell
we don't really know how they got this
but from what we can tell this channel
is the first one to post it it does
include two legitimate new shots of the
Guardians one in the multi-colored suits
floating from the Bowie toward that
fleshy structure from this angle we can
see that this tracks in the red suit and
quill in the yellow one also
interestingly a brand new look at nebula
alone on the bridge of the Bowie as an
electric current courses through the
controls and the bulkheads this is
definitely new nebula has their new mesh
weave arm and this is the Bowie and that
VFX electricity looks legit several
layers deep in the scene casting light
and Shadow across Karen Gillen so what's
going on here has the Bowie been
immobilized has it been super charged on
a new power source where's the rest of
the crew James Gunn told total film that
volume 3 will redefine the whole
Guardians Trilogy as really the rocket
story and back in his no fat tweet he
said that we will see the full art for
every character so yes going into this
movie expectations are very high we
definitely need an unabashed win of a
superhero movie in 20 23. comment down
below with what you're most looking
forward to from guardians volume 3 and a
reminder to subscribe to our new channel
the Deep dive you can support Instagram
it's a merch at nerdride.shop follow me
on Instagram and Twitter at eavos follow
new Rockstar subscribe to new rockstars
for more analysis everything you love
thanks for watching bye
[Music]